hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast sonal rotor ultra
centrifugation an effective tool for
nanoparticle separations at large scale
my name is marcus kluse and lvlu
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by beckman culture life
sciences
the views expressed in this webinar are
those of the speaker and not of
technical life sciences
for more information on beckman culture
please visit beckmann.com
resources i would like to remind
everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the after
question box and click
on the send button you can also see at
the top of the page multiple tabs
please click through our related
applications
upcoming and on demand webinars as well
as links to the cell culture heroes
webpage
you may be our next cultural hero also
please notice you can share this webinar
on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab and found that
is found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box
located at the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuum education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i'd like to now introduce the presenters
dr alexander vitterman professor of
colloid chemistry and dr simona busch
senior researcher of colloid chemistry
both at the university of constance
germany
this is a special honor for me since i
have done my studies there as well
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
after vitamin drish you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for the kind introduction mr
news so
the following minutes we would like to
discuss with you
sorting of nanoparticles as scales
ranging from small scales
up to large scales by centrifugal
techniques that allow for proper
fractionations
well why is sorting of nanoparticles
such an important
issue in modern nanoscience well the
properties
of nanoparticles strongly depend on
parameters such as
size shape and composition so as an
example here we see
gold nano rods of varying aspect ratio
now the aspect ratio is defined as the
length to width ratio
and following the aspect ratio size and
shape of the particles will change
and you see this has a drastic impact on
the optical
and plasmonic properties of these
nanoparticles
in the lower row we have a second
example so here we have
core shell particles so these are silica
spheres
coating with a thin gold layer of
varying density
so following the density of the shell
also the composition of these core shell
particles will change
and again this has a drastic impact on
the properties of the particles
so if you rely on a synthesis protocol
that gives you that vary
in their size density or composition
so which you refer to as polydispersity
then you should think about
fractionation which will bring you in
the position to precisely determine the
properties of your
nanoparticles moreover having
access to uniform particles is also key
towards assembling nanoparticles into
hierarchically organized tuber
structures
so as an example here you see uniform
gold nanoparticles with a cubic shape
who are aligned into crystalline
superstructures
now before we will come back to science
let me briefly introduce you where we
are from
so we are now working since almost nine
years with university of constance
so consensus is located in the very
south of
germany and the old town of constance
directly borders on switzerland and the
town gave its name
to the lake constance which is
surrounded by
three countries germany switzerland
and austria now our campus is located on
a
headland which subdivides lake constance
into a lake uber lingan which is a
famous
sailing resort and the so-called
underser
which was and there's the isle of now
which was a monastery island
during medieval ages
okay the university of constance and you
can see here our campus
on the lower left was founded in 1966
so it's one of germany's youngest
universities
and it's also one of germany's
universities of
excellence now our neighbor is the
isle of myna which you might know so
this is a
flower island which attracts about one
and a half millions of visitors each
year
so in spring you could see here millions
of beautiful
tulips now as i told you
austria switzerland and even bavaria
are actually very close so there you
have nice opportunities for hiking and
you can
enjoy such a marvelous lake and mountain
views
now let's come back to science why are
we interested in sorting of
nanoparticles well our research
activities
are centered around supracollidal
assembly
which means that we would like to take
nanoparticles
let's say as a sort of colloidal lego
bricks
and then our aim is to assemble them
into
more complex structure so this starts
with
clusters of a limited number of
particles which are often referred to
as colloidal molecules as they share
configurations with true molecules
so as a an example here you see dimers
which you can consider as collide oxygen
molecules
or heterodimers which you can consider
as
colloidal hydrogen fluoride molecules
now these colloidal molecules take on a
key role in supra
colloidal assembly as they can have the
potential to bridge the gap
between the single particles at the nano
scale
and such highly complex materials
so this is actually a colloidal tetras
deck
so an assembly of tetrahedral shaped
particles
and this is material is often considered
as the holy grail of a photonic material
as it provides large and robust optical
band gaps along the whole range of
visible light
and this comes along with birefringence
and low refractive index contrasts
however in order to get access to such
dream materials much more has to be done
to make colloidal molecules
available at large scales and this is
where
sorting is an issue as you will see in a
minute
now having access to reasonable amount
of colloidal molecules
should bring us in the position to start
developing strategies
that allow precise assembly into the
target superstructure which we are
aiming
at so now the collidal molecules
which we would like to discuss with you
today
are assembly of this uniform polystyrene
particles which you see
on on the left side so they are highly
uniform and can be prepared at large
scales
so here sorting is not yet an issue now
these particles have dimensions in the
order of hundred nanometers which mean
that these
particles and small clusters build their
off
under light brownian motion which
prevails over
sedimentation now how to make these
collidal molecules well we basically
mix oil and water and we add
the particles to be assembled into
clusters
to one of the two fluid phases actually
it doesn't matter to which one because
after emulsification
which is performed by powerful
ultrasound
they will be trapped to the surface of
the emulsion droplets in either case
now the ultrasound helps us to control
the size
and the dispersity of the emulsion
droplets
so if we have a closer look on such an
emulsion droplet we can see
that indeed the particles are trapped at
the surface of the emulsion droplet
and this is mediated by a minimization
of surface energy
so the phenomenon is referred to as the
pickering effect
now the emulsion droplets serves as a
template
and for the assembly into clusters and
if we now
evaporate the dispersed droplets phase
then we create strong
capillary forces which make the
particles come together
and assemble into clusters of
well-defined geometries
so here you have now an overview of the
reaction result so we get a mixture
starting
from single particles particle dimers
drivers tetramers pandamas and hexamers
now the fact that we get a mixture of
various species
is a direct outcome of the random
distribution
of the particles on the emulsion
droplets
so hence sorting is an issue and this is
where centrifugation
and does the scene so now let's start
with some
basic consideration now if exposed to a
centrifugal field
particle sediment at the rate which is
defined by the sedimentation coefficient
now the sedimentation coefficient is
defined
as the ratio of the effective mass of
the particles
and its friction coefficient the later
depends
also on the particle shape now the
effective mass of the particle
is the difference between the actual
mass of the particles
and the mass of the fluid which is
displaced by the particles
now for spherical particles we can
express
the equation so the sedimentation
coefficient as a function
of two important parameters so the first
one is particle size
defined as the particle radius or the
hydrodynamic effective radius of the
particles
and the second one is the particle
density which we refer to as
buoyant density of the particle
so the sedimentation coefficient depends
on these two
important parameters moreover
if you look at the equation in the blue
box
the value in the bracket will become
zero if you create a density environment
for the sedimentating particle where the
density
of the fluid layer matches exactly the
bond
of the particle and so at this point
sedimentation will come to a full stop
and we can make use of this
by bending particles according to their
buoyant density
as you will see in a second now
still nowadays the most common technique
of centrifugation is called
differential centrifugation maybe all of
you will be familiar with this technique
this is exactly where
you form a pallet of agglomerated
particle
at the bottom of your centrifuge tube
now
differential centrifugation starts with
having
homogeneous distribution of the various
particle population
within a centrifuge tube and after
centrifugation
even some of the smallest and lightest
particles will end up in the pellet
because some of them are initially
located close to the bottom of the
centrifuge
tube so in other words there's only a
portion
of the smallest and
lightest particles which you can be
which can be recovered in pure form
now differential centrifugation works
out reasonably
well if the sedimentation coefficient
of the particle populations to be
separated from one another
differ by at least one order in
magnitude
well way better separations can be
achieved by using density gradient
centrifugation
and there are actually two different
direction how to perform density
gradient
centrifugation the first one is termed
isopysonic separation the method is also
known as
buoyant density separation because here
you classify the particles according to
their buoyant density
on the right hand side we see an example
from the very early days
of this technique where kayla and lloyd
use polystyrene latex particle
for precisely determining the density of
polystyrene
now the polystyrene latex is loaded on
top of a
sugrose density gradient and now the
particles will travel down their way
through the gradient until they reach a
position the so-called isoprismic point
where the density of the fluid
exactly matches the buoyant density of
the particles so this is where
if you remember this is where
sedimentation comes to a full stop
and we can now bend the particle
according to their
density and this provides really
excellent resolutions
so here you have to build density
gradients
which at their lower end um
have lower densities than the actual
density of the particles whereas
at the heaviest end of the density
gradient the density
exceeds the buoyant density of the
particle
so this is an equilibrium technique and
so you get
bending in discrete zones according to
the buoyant density of the particles
now there's one isopristic separation
which actually became
famous so today it's often referred to
as the most
beautiful experiment in biology
now this experiment was designed by
meselson and stahl
in the late 1950s so at that time
the double helix nature of dna was just
discovered
and there was a debate among the
three different mechanisms of dna
replication
now meselson and stahl could solve this
issue
by designing an elegant approach which
starts
with they let dna
grow in a nitrogen 15 culture medium
which results in dna which has a
higher buoyant density than regular dna
formed in an n14 culture medium
then they let a first replication of the
dna molecule proceed
and this experiment is then carried out
now in an n14 culture medium
then they centrifuge the reaction
product in a cesium chloride density
gradient
allowing for isoprismic bending of dna
now the debate was among three different
mechanisms
the first one is called
semi-conservative replication mechanism
and it was proposed by watson and crick
so here the double-stranded molecule is
divided
first into two parental strengths which
serve
as template for the construction
of new complementary daughter strengths
other scientists believed that
bonding of the double helix is too
strong to allow for
a first division so they thought that
the newly formed dna
must be a full copy of the
double-stranded of the original
double-stranded molecule
in the third mechanism segments of newly
formed dna
together with segments um of
parental dna will enter into the newly
formed
dna double strands and now we can
classify the potential reaction products
according to their weight
and for the conservative replication
mechanism
we would expect a population of heavier
dna together with a population of lidar
dna
whereas for the other two mechanism we
would expect reaction products of medium
density
now in terms of isoprismic
centrifugation this would refer
either to having two different density
populations
or having just a single density
population
and now meselson and stahl found in
their experiment
a single band of dna
thus they could rule out the
conservative replication mechanism
but there are still two options so
meselson and stall
solved this by doing a second dna
replication
again in an n14 culture medium
and so they predicted the potential
reaction outcome
and here you see an overview for the two
remaining mechanism
and again we can now classify the
potential reaction
products according to their density so
we have
now two populations for in the
semi-conservative replication mechanism
whereas there's a single reaction
product expected for the dispersed
replication so now in terms of isoprism
separation this is two bands versus a
single band
and yeah meselson install finally
they could detect two different
populations of dna
thus they could verify the
semi-conservative replication
mechanism that was proposed by watson
and crick
so now let's discuss about the second
way to perform density gradient
centrifugation
so this is alternative to classifying
nanoparticle populations according to
the density
so here the particle populations
travel down the density gradient at a
rate which is
a different rates which are specified by
their
different sedimentation coefficients and
here we just classify
the particles according to their
sedimentation coefficient
now this technique was pioneered also in
1951 by myron braga who used this
technique for the purification of plant
viruses
and here the important prerequisite
is that the density of the particles
must be always
higher than the highest density within
the gradient
on the other hand the sample density
which means
particles plus this person should have a
lower density
than the lowest density within the
gradient
so this is the pre-requisite to make the
particle settle into
visually at the rate exactly defined by
their sedimentation coefficient
and of course you have to stop such an
experiment before equilibration
otherwise you would end up in a pallet
now i would like to hand over to my
colleague
simone busch she has long-term
experience in carrying out
centrifugations and she will let you
know about the experimental realization
so thanks alexander and welcome from the
lab
so the whole story starts with
constructing a density gradient so we
need a gradient
in a centrifuge tube there are several
ways
but the most widely used method is an
over
layering method so we start with the
dense solution
and then we layer successively lower
densities on the top from a pipette
so we end up with a discontinuous
gradient
with a total volume of 35 milliliters we
can
receive a continuous gradient eventually
a linear gradient
by allowing the gradient to diffuse but
this procedure takes quite a long time
so we are using this method only
if our low of if
our solution the bottom is really high
concentrated and therefore
extremely viscous so in our case 55
eight percent and
so loading the sample works in exactly
the same way
and we recommend again using a pipette
because the pressure is
easy to control and therefore the flow
of the sample on the top of the gradient
so it takes a little bit of practice
and the traditional way of constructing
a continuous gradient is to use a
two-chamber gradient maker
here a simple model with two identical
chambers
connected by a tapped channel and the
mixing chamber has an
outlet so the device is set up with the
mixing chamber
on a magnetic steering with the outlet
tube leading via the
peristaltic pump to the bottom of a
huge tube so how does it work so
the high density solution is filled in
the left
chamber and the low density solution
is filled in the mixing chamber
and then we switch on the pump
we switch on the magnetic steerer and
we open the connecting tabs so first one
one between the two chambers and then
the one who is located next to the
peristaltic pump
so a few experimental inside so it's
really important
that there are no air bubbles in the
connection tube so
for this we fill first the mixing
chamber
with the low density solution open the
tab
let the solution flow
until the end of the channel close the
tab again and then
we fill inside the high density solution
so it's also important that in both
chambers are
steer bars and this ensures the same
height of the density solutions
in this chambers and at the end it's
also
really important to regulate
the power of the steer bar um
to avoid air bubbles and to avoid an
early cut
of the flow in the direction of the
peristaltic pump
so such a scheme often looks more than
it is
so here is our setup on the left side
we have the gradient maker and the
magnetic steerer
in the middle the peristaltic pump and
on the
right side a particular tube so
for rate zone separation a thin wall
ultra clear tube is recommended
by ultra clear okay you want to see your
bands and you also want to see
low concentrated bands and thin
volt because you want to have a few
options when it comes to isolating
particular bands
but i want to talk about this in a few
slides
now we have the density gradient with
the sample on the top
and what about the rotor
so there are several different rotors
available
for instance the fixed angle rotor and
the vertical rotor and the spinning
bucket rotor
so the two most commonly used rotors are
the fixed angle in the swinging bucket
rotor
so the selection of a rotor depends on
sample volume
number of sample particles to be
separated
the particle size and or the density
desired runtime and desired quality of
separation
and for the rate
zone density gradient method in which
the maximum
resolution of sample components is
needed
excellent separation can be achieved if
we are using swinging outdoor tours
because of the length of the tubes in
the horizontal position
the sample separation run times are
very long due to the
increased distance the particles will
travel
for um for effective separation
and sorry and
additionally the separated zones remain
at the same position in the tube during
and after
centrifugation and this contributes to
an excellent sorting efficiency
so we optimized the strategy for sorting
colloidal molecules
so uh here you see at centrifuge tubes
with banded colliding molecules they're
all
well bended into discrete bands and here
we broke
different sets of experimental
parameters
and we also applied different extraction
strategies
for instance we can
use a canola and collect the particles
from above
and it also works very well if we inject
a needle from the side
so we can selectively extract a specific
band we can also use a piercing unit and
discharge
the fractions from below but sometimes
you want to have
a 100 percent clear fraction
and if you use for example a canola and
go
through a band it can happen
that you sweep particles from a higher
located band away and it can be that you
contaminate
the desired ban so it's sometimes better
to use
first tube slicer so you have to
tube you push a knife through the tube
you collect the fluid from the top and
remove the slide the knife and then you
use again your canola and collect the
desired band
so here you can see some fraction of our
coil molecules we got
so we have pure monomers pure dimers
trimers tetramers pandemic and hexamers
so
this is a visual impression from
scanning electron micrographs
so let's combine them with quantitative
data
so we here we have the
particle size distribution of all our
six
fractions of colliding molecules
and they are basically free of
any foreign species so now
separation using this swinging rotor
allows for separate for separation
of about 20 milligrams of colloidal
molecules
so this is sufficient for analytical
purposes
and indeed we could use these particles
to probe hydrodynamic properties
of complex of of complex particles such
as diffusion coefficient
but as shown in the beginning we are
really interested
to build sub super structures and
therefore
our wish is to have one gram of coral
molecules or better two grams so
um so
how about large scales alexander
thank you simona for sharing this
important experimental details
and letting us know about small scale
separations
the question that you ask is
how to do a large scale and there a
method came to our
attention that was established already
in the 1960s
by norman g anderson at oak ridge
for biological separations so this
method was
even used for the commercial
purification of influenza vaccines
but to our great surprise it had never
been used
for sorting of synthetic particles and
we are actually the first ones doing so
so now this method has two major
characteristics
the first one is that you have a bowl
shaped hollow rotor which replaces the
need of having any centrifuge tubes
so this hollow ball-shaped rotor hosts
large volumes of density gradients
and the second important characteristic
is that this rotor can be loaded
and unloaded dynamically this means that
we can load the gradient
and then the sample and later we can
harvest the zones of
banded particle while the rotor is
spinning
and this avoids any reorientation of
fluid layer during the full operation
and contributes
to an excellent sorting efficiency
now here you see a top view of a solar
rotor on the right hand side
with an inner core now this
core with four vertical scepter allows
for
a compartmentalization of the rotor
chamber
and thus helps to minimize adwords flow
of fluid
moreover it contains channels that allow
to selectively address
a rotor sender and rotor edge
and this is the pre-requisite for
dynamic loading
now if you compare now a centrifuge tube
in a swing out rotor with a sonar rotor
then you can consider the solar rotor as
an
extension of the centrifuge tube by 360
degree
now there's still an important
difference
you should be aware of because the
profile of the density gradient
is very crucial to it to get proper
separations
so for instance if we build a density
gradient which is linear in volume
it will be also linear in radius if
placed
in a centrifuge tube however because of
the bowl-shaped geometry of the solar
rotor
it will correspond to a concave profile
in radius
if put in a zonal rotor
okay so now let's explain you how
dynamic loading is performed so we start
with spinning the rotor at a reduced
rate of let's say 2000 rpm
and then we start with pumping in the
lightest part of the gradient to be
built within the rotor chamber and this
portion of fluid is
pumped towards the edge of the rotor now
this fluid layer will be then
displaced by layers of next higher
densities
until the gradient is fully loaded
now once the gradient is fully loaded
then we can start
with loading the sample which is
introduced via the center line so this
is shown in subfigure b
then we remove the two-way fluid seal
that allowed for dynamic loading
and now we accelerate the rotor to the
speed which is actually
required for proper sorting of the
nanoparticles
so once the nanoparticles are probably
bended into discrete zones
of the very different for the very
different
particle populations then we can again
decelerate
the rotor to a reduced rate of 2000 rpm
then we will again mount the two way
fluid seal
and now we can harvest the zone of
bended particles by pumping in
a very dense solution of gradient
material towards the rotor edge
thus displacing the zone of
offended particles via the center line
now again my colleague simone will
explain you about the experimental
realization
so this is a view of our lab when we
started with
zone rotor centrifugation here you can
see the most
simple setup where you are able to carry
out
a sonar run so we just need several
graduated beakers for the gradient
preparation
and a peristaltic pump for the loading
and deloading process
and of course the sonar rotor and
the core which is placed in the rotor
bowl
so at the moment we are working on
further optimization of this technique
so here we have an online spectrum media
that is communicating with an adapted
software
specific valve and a fraction collector
and this should in the future allow us
to make the system
automatically decide if a fraction is
worse to be collected or not
so back to our collide
clusters so after zona rotate
centrifugation we can use
this fraction collector to collect all
the zones
now in a typical experiment we collect
more than 80 fractions
20 ml each and then we do a careful
analysis
of all these fractions so we measure the
absorption
absorption absorption profile that you
can see
at the top and we also measure the
density of all these fractions to probe
the density gradient
profile and we also measure the particle
size distribution of every fraction
to precisely know the composition of all
these fractions
so let's have a closer look
into this we are building a step
gradient in this example
however the density steps will even out
during centrifugation
and so the profile they convert into a
continuous one
and here and here we are using a convex
gradient because the shape of this
gradient
profile is believed to provide
particular good separations
now we can overlay the density gradient
profile
and the absorption pattern and so we can
now
map the zones of banded particles here
we have the monomers the thymus trimers
and tetramers and all larger species are
accumulated near the rotor wall because
we are mainly interested in having
larger yields of dimers and dryness in
this case
okay since we know the composition of
all the fractions we can
also experimentally deconvolute this
absorption pattern in to contributions
of single particle
populations as you can see here
so together with this we can set up a
full separation map which you can see on
the left and we can also
optimize the gradient profile for
different sets of particles
well um i should mention that at the
moment
we can achieve to get more than 600
milligrams of coral molecules solid
however the actual bottleneck is here
not the solenoid rotor
which would allow for higher capacity
probably 2 grams or even more however
the actual bottleneck is not
uh the preparation of our colin molecule
so
we need here further improvement
uh in upscaling our approach
and now let's have a closer look
at the fractions that we receive from
zone load identification
so these are pure monomers your diamonds
and your dry mass and a fraction
that is essentially rich in practical
tetramers
so 100 purity of
tetrahedral clusters need still further
optimization
in regard to tailoring density gradient
profiles
so in order to allow you to evaluate
the configurations on this electron
micrographs
we had to dilute all these fractions and
so in um so
a typical fraction would like would look
like this
this is a fraction of pure coli oxygen
molecules
and we have them now in great quantities
to build up superstructures
so far we talked about rate zone
separation
where we sorted this colliding molecules
according to their sedimentation
coefficient
but how about how about isopoisonic
separation
so in our
latest experiment we probed a mixture of
polystyrene particles
pmma particles and hybrids of the two
materials
so you can see that we can bend them
well according to their bionthen
bion density and we can use this
technique even
to precisely detect the density of this
complex dumbbell shaped hybrid particle
and even more we get the density profile
the conventional methods and
averaging so back to alexander
so thank you simona also for letting us
know about
large scale separations carried out in a
sonar rotor
now let me briefly summarize so we
started today's
journey with the preparation of collidal
molecules
starting with the assembly of
nanoparticles which is moderated by
emulsion droplets
and i hope that we could convince you
that one can even prepare
well-defined colloidal supraparticles
from nanoparticles however the fact that
we get the mixture of different species
is birth centrifugation end of the scene
and there you should
remember that there are two basic ways
of how to perform density gradient
centrifugations
the first one is rate solar separations
where particles are classified according
to their
sedimentation coefficient which depends
on both
size and density
now this technique is very versatile and
it can be
applied almost to all types of
nanoparticles so nanoparticles
that have distributions either in size
or density or both
the other alternative technique is
classification according to the buoyant
density
so this technique is termed isopysonic
centrifugation
and this can be applied to composite
particles
such as core shell particles or other
hybrid
particles now buoyant density
centrifugation
offers extraordinary resolutions
because particles can be well bended
according to the density
then we started with discussion of
yeah centrifugations density gradient
centrifugation at small scales
and here swing out rotas provide
an excellent solution so they offer us
perf almost perfect sorting efficiencies
so you could see here that the different
zones of let's say up to 12 different
particle populations shown in this
centrifuge tubes can be bended in
well-defined
discrete zones however
if you require larger larger amounts
so let's say if you want to go towards
the multiple gram scale
then we would like highly recommend you
so looking into solar rotor
centrifugation
where a hollow ball-shaped rotor replace
the need of having centrifuged tubes
and this allows for large-scale
fractionation of nanoparticles
now let me think the people who did
actually the work
so the colloidal molecules that we
discussed today
and all centrifugations ever carried out
by
simone plush roven stukat prepared
the particles that we used for extending
sonar rotor centrifugation towards
isopyclic separations he also studied
the hydrodynamic properties of the
colloidal molecules
which actually helped us a lot to remove
this
centrifugal fraction routines
then we would like to acknowledge
a support from key facilities of our
university namely the particle analysis
center
and here we would like to thank brigade
the personnel who helped us
a lot during performing sonar rotor
centrifugation
then we enjoyed fruitful collaborations
with many
partners and we would also like to
acknowledge lutz erhart from beckmann
culda
who encouraged us moving into this field
of sonal rotor centrifugation
finally i would like to thank all of you
for listening
and watching and now we are ready to
accept your questions
yes thank you dr vitterman and dr blush
for your informative presentation
will you now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
our first question is a very exciting
presentation
you present you presented separations
that look
just very good does it always look so
good
how much experience is needed to get
there yeah so thanks for the questions
so well we have now several years of
experience in performing centrifugal
identification
however carrying out proper
identification is not a mystery it's
uh predictable so it's pure physics and
actually um already the result of our
first fractionation was more than we
expected so we had
a bending of six different particle
populations and
after further refinements we could
extend this to
up to 14 different populations and
i think having
a glam hand and having the right
equipment
such as a swinging outdoor door and
proper recovery
solutions help a lot if i may add so
we recommend you to not to stick to
protocols
used by others that work out well for
other types of nanoparticles
so it's better to design a gradient
which perfectly
fits your needs and as simone said
it's just basic physics so you there are
just some
uh simple conditions that should be
fulfilled
and then you can easily develop a
strategy that really
works out very well for your sets of
nanoparticles
and nowadays simulation routines
offered either by the manufacturer of
your centrifuge
or which are available
by open source domains can help you
finding proper separation routines
okay next question is you show different
gradient separation techniques
which of those techniques do you prefer
separation by density or separation by
size
okay so you make this decision dependent
on the actual separation tasks they have
so for example
the different populations of alkaline
molecules
that we showed have the same density and
for this reason they
can be separated only by rates on a
separate
centrifugation but not by isoprism
exploration for example
yeah yeah maybe um
you should even think about combining
the two different strategies
so this could even improve further
sorting quality
so for example if you consider colloidal
molecules
which are assembled from two different
sets of particles
which differ in their density in this
specific case it would be helpful to
start with an isopysonic separation
first then you have fractions that share
the same density
and then you could do a rate solar
separation to sort them according to
their size
so you should think about combination of
the two strategy
and this is also something which is our
on our agenda
great the third question did you compare
those separations with
chromatography and how does that compare
yeah well chromatography of course works
very well for molecules
and also for small nanoparticles
however you should consider that
nanoparticles can get stuck
in the pores of the stationary phase
of a when you do chromatography so
moreover the
method is limited to small scales let's
say to the
um scales of a few milligrams
and yeah
yeah maybe i would like to add that
beyond centrifugation and chromatography
there are other techniques such for
example membrane filtration
they also allow for nanoparticle
separation and
however we prefer identification because
of
the better resolution of the
centrifugation and
the sedimentation time of a particle
exposed to a centrifugal field
scales with the radius squared and which
provides a remarkable
resulting power and that's why we use
the identification techniques
next one is a very specific question
anyone using
for foot and mouth disease virus
particles
i think maybe we can go a little more
general because
many people compare virus particles and
nanoparticles what
would you say to that from a
professional point of view
yeah so in the early days uh so if you
talk about sony rotor separation
uh when it was established by norman g
anderson
so the idea was sorting uh viruses
so you can you can really sort the whole
range of
biological species starting let's say
from macromolecules like dna
and then you can go up to whole cells
and this also includes a virus particles
so it works very well
so you have seen the pioneering
experiment carried out by myron parker
already in 1951 we exactly used this
method for the purification of viruses
so
these strategies that we showed you will
work very well
also for viruses
okay so we'll have time for some more
questions
obviously all the questions are already
answered by the great presentation
and i want to remind our audience that
those questions were not
asked or answered today and those
that come in during the on-demand period
they will be answered via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
directly by dr polish and dr vitamin
so if there are no further questions so
far i want to thank you again dr vitamin
and dr plush
do you happen to have any final comments
for the audience
yeah we just want to say thank you to
everyone for listening
so feel free to contact us if you have
any further questions
we wish you best of luck when performing
your centrifugal separations goodbye
goodbye before we go i'd like to thank
the audience
myself for joining us today and for the
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for or
have not been asked today
and those who submit will be submitted
later as i just mentioned will be
addressed by the speaker
to a later time point of view via email
address
we would like to thank once again dr
vitterman and dr bluish for their
time today and for the important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor my company bagna culture
life sciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share the email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's it thank you everybody and
goodbye